[Music]  welcome to the future  it's drew barrymore and we're so excited  to share the secret behind  how we can get so many of our amazing  guests  into the cbs broadcast center in new  york city  where we're filming the show even if  they're in los angeles and can't travel  to new york see my friend dr elisa  pressman  she's the one sitting with me or  is she that's right dr  elisa is in our la studio beaming into  new york  like something out of star trek  it's incredible  the cameras are controlled by our new  york control room  so there's not even a camera operator in  the room  with the guest so when  guests are looking to get away from it  all  they can come join us in new york i mean  la  but really it's in new york even though  they're in la but  they're kind of in new york oh well you  know what you get it  [Music]  [Music]  you